I'm 3D today.
I'm 3D.
I want to be 3D.
Cuffing baby.
Actually, baby, my throat is a little.
I've had to be recording so many things lately, so...
Oh, Chad is frozen.
Holds up two, says 3D.
I know how to count.
Why?
I'm quiet?
Maybe...
Everything's messed up today.
Sorry, hold on.
Ah, today will be a bit of a shorter stream.
But you guys...
Oh!
Wait.
I'm confused.
It says...
It says my mic is coming from somewhere else.
why does it say it's coming from somewhere else
the mic is coming from inside the house then who was phone
maybe that's better maybe that is better but why
whatever it's probably fine maybe hold on if I do it wait
I'm going to test something
okay I think it's I think it's working I think is working um
turn the bgm down and said i don't know anymore i
don't know anymore is that better oh i'm getting frustrated
i've already had to deal with so many tech things today that
frustrated me um not the 3d surprisingly surprisingly but i
figured i want to be in for this because because when you
are a 3d actor no not 3d a voice actor when you are a voice
actor you do not just act with your voice you must act with
your body so I thought I'm
gonna play this game
I'm gonna play this game!
Thank you for the super chats!
Thank you!
Like I said, it's a bit of a shorter stream today because I
have so much I need to do actually after this and before
this too.
I have so much that I knew that I was working on before this
and we'll have to do after this.
So, yeah!
My brain is...
My brain is all scrambled!
So, forgive me.
Forgive me for my brain today.
Busy time this week, especially.
So, yeah.
Okie dokie.
I have a preventative measure, hopefully, not be struck in
by YouTube gods today.
And that is a privacy screen.
First is a privacy screen.
And second is sample, sample, sample, sample, sample,
sample, sample, sample, sample, sample, sample, sample,
sample, sample, sample.
sample so we should we should be good probably yeah audio
jungle except sample sample sample sample sample sample
sample sample sample yeah yeah it's a it's a visual audio
jungle visual jungle if you will yeah sample text sample
text Ipsum lorem Ipsum lorem So yeah, we'll put those up
when we get to the stuff, actually.
It's my birthday!
That I adopted, baby!
Happy birthday!
Yeah.
You've seen other VTubers use metal bars.
Well, I'm not like other VTubers.
I use sample text.
You look even cuter in 3D!
MCA the voice in the bus goes blah blah blah blah blah I've
been copyrighted by wheels on the bus before honestly
there's so many times often that I get copyrighted on stream
and lose ad well I don't even really make ad revenue anyway
because I have ads off um so if you see ads on my streams
they are They are not from me.
They're not from me.
The cure to pride brain is simply jive and...
But I often get demonetized on stream so often.
I just don't mention it.
It's very, actually quite common.
So, um...
If I get demonetized or copyright struck, as long as it's
not like a strike on my channel.
I don't really care.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I don't care so much so yeah, I did already download some
packs We'll go through the ones that I downloaded and Some
of them I know like I know the scene right I'm like I'm a
professional.
I got this My fingers are
My fingers But some of them I don't know really so much so
Did I hear lost revenue?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Blue Riddle!
Happy to see 3D Vito!
Happy birthday!
Wait, can I...
This is... Wait.
Heart.
Wait.
I can't lift my arms up to it.
Heart.
No, no, no, no.
No, come back.
Heart.
Happy birthday!
Why didn't you mention that earlier?
What the heck?
Ugh.
My sleeves are too funky sometimes.
Who needs to add revenue when you have...
Wait, one second, hold on.
I gotta take off my headphones.
They're all tied up.
One second.
Where'd they go?
Oh, there it is.
Are they backwards?
Actually, that's impossible because they're the kind that
like they on my ears.
You know what I mean?
They...
I take them and I go...
It's like that on my ear.
They...
It's...
Yeah, they're like little hooks.
They're like little hooks on them.
Yeah, so I...
So I can...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't have...
Because I...
Over the head ones...
my ears stick out a lot right so it smushes them and it
hurts and then I had been getting ear infections recently so
I stopped ear at my IEMs and so now I have my cause swoops
what do you call them I don't know yeah because I they're
not elf ears they're just a little pointy yeah but they like
that bread on top the shroops my shroops my cost shroops the
brand is cost though k-o-s-s-s and they cost me a whopping
20 and they're great i love them so much they have been like
the best investment ever
They're awesome What a deal what a deal Crazy
If y'all don't understand that hooks swoop, they do though,
right?
They do
$20 is $20 They work great.
They work really great So for those who don't know know the
choice or voicer which I don't really even know that much I
kind of well it's not that I avoided watching people play
because it's not really playing it's you voice act scenes
and stuff like that but when people were playing I was I was
I was out and about so I didn't have time to watch people's
VODs um but now thanks Vinny is it a Vinny game actually guy
must be confused as see vtubers playing it i can't believe
veto is playing a vinnie vine sauce game i've met that guy a
couple times before though we hung out in new york me and
him and maddie maddie oh that's raspberry who uh draws a
bunch of metal gear comics and stuff my favorite tv show is
on i love watching this ghost thank you for the hug of super
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for all the streams this week.
We don't can't wait for the goofy doves you got cooking up.
Yes, it's a Vinny game.
That's crazy.
Wait.
Fiznuma, I saw you on the site that I downloaded things
from.
I was like...
I literally...
I literally pointed like that and went...
I was like...
I know that guy.
Why?
I haven't known if people made a voice pack of you.
were something.
I saw some VTuber voice pack things on there too.
I was like, wow.
What site?
I don't know.
Doki linked it to me.
Um, I downloaded them from where's, oh, um game banana.
3D Minto Quito!
Yeah.
I was like, Doki, where do you?
How do I do this?
She helped me out.
Because when I first was talking with Nimmy about it, she
was like, she was like, you have to go through like discords
and stuff.
And I was like, oh, maybe I won't do it.
I don't have time for that.
And I was like, Doki, where'd you get yours?
And she was like, oh, I got them from this website.
So I was like, Doki, easy.
And I found some that I thought seemed kind of fun.
I said I picked out some from things that I'm familiar with
and some things that I'm like I don't know what this is so
we'll just we'll just do our best and by we I mean me
I can't believe my oh she knows my other shirt of any vine
saws what do you mean your shirt
what do you mean your shirt Yoki is being the room wait I
can always download more if we get through the ones that i
have pretty quickly um we won't do we'll do what's the
difference between dub dub mode impersonate voice clips and
hear your dub as a video you can re-record as many times as
you wish in this mode but you cannot hear your recordings
until the dub is complete this mode is used as special dub
voice packs oh jay zoe thank you for that thank you i'm in
tokyo for work for a few days any recommendations Depends on
what you want to do, right?
Dub mode is the one popular to do.
Okay, we'll do dub mode then.
Small live, welcome to Babusha, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, sir.
I say...
Where am I?
My hand's going crazy.
I'm trying to think of, like, a good...
Wait!
I have a new place to tell you guys about!
I can't gatekeep this.
It's so good!
Tintan, thank you for the fact it did!
It's so good.
There is...
There is a...
An Italian place in Sunshine City.
Hold on, let me look it up.
Italian place in Sunshine City.
Sunshine City.jpg.
Caesarea, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
But, it's a little, it's a little pricey.
It's a little pricey, but they have the...
Do you mean as an Ikebukuro?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Ikebukuro Sunshine City.
It...
is they have the best garlic bread I've ever, ever had.
Oh, the garlic and the loaf is like this big.
They're like actually like this big.
This big.
This of garlic bread.
And, okay, hold on.
Let me find the place.
Oh, wait, no, restaurant, restaurant, restaurant.
It's on the...
Fourth, third, fourth, third.
Oh, I'm starting to lag a little bit.
Sorry, guys.
I saw one, it's on the fourth or third floor.
And hold on.
Restaurant, restaurant, restaurant.
I'm looking it up.
Yes!
Aguil, Aguil, that's the place, that's the place.
Hot dog, Luvia!
Thank you so much for the tang!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Agio.
A-G-I-O.
How'd you find it so fast?
It's so... Oh my gosh, they're garlic bread.
It's so good.
It's so good!
It's my recent super Oshisume, my super recommendation.
Happy MGS Master Collection Volume 2.
Yay!
If you thought that there was no Metal Gear stuff today, no,
no, no.
Sayyumito's gonna show off her vocal chops on my birthday!
Choco-Dacu!
Happy birthday!
And she's in the third dimension.
She's like a lot of eyeball birthday stuff.
It is, actually.
Yeah.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the fine content!
Happy, happy birthday, Choco-Dacu!
Thank you for the peek!
Thank you!
Okay, we'll do dub mode.
Look at these!
Oh wait.
Let's get rid of the, I'll get rid of the privacy screen.
The privacy screen for right now.
I have a few things.
I didn't know how many, like I said, it's not going to be
the longest stream today because I'm quite busy.
I have some things that I have to get done today.
So, I have some fun things here I thought that they might be
fine I thought they might be fine so um when I was talking
to Doki about it too she was like don't pick movies only
pick video games and so I picked a lot of video game things
but then I was like I don't know it's probably fine oh
Raiders thank you hello Hello, hello, hello.
I didn't see you raided, but thank you so much!
I've been waiting for the stream ever since it escaped
Vinny's containment.
I can't see him, too.
Thank you for the...
For the gifted.
We're seeing Glitch Rays, thank you for the fine gifted.
Rock Raid?
Wait a...
Oh, Nikia!
Hi!
Hi, everybody.
I hope you had a...
uh...
a, uh...
rousing good time.
on her street.
I tried.
I tried to think of...
Godfoul!
Thank you!
There we go, thank you!
A lot of birthdays in August because people get busy in
December.
Way back, thank you.
Give me the gift.
No, thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Oh my gosh.
Good one.
My thumb is broken.
Leia, thank you for the tiny bear.
Thank you.
Eyes not good is MGS crab battle there.
We have...
Oh, wait.
This is missing some.
Wait.
I have to restart the game.
Hold on.
Wait.
Why is it missing some?
One second.
I added more.
I like had a whole Metal Gear pack.
Deku versus Todoroki sounds insane.
I'm so excited for it.
I have no idea what it is.
I don't know at all.
I have no idea.
How?
Is it in a folder?
Yeah, it showed up earlier.
That's why I'm confused.
Like, I did actually check that he showed up.
My birthday's tomorrow!
Guess it counts since tomorrow in Japan.
Nontan, happy early birthday!
Yeah, it's weird that they disappeared.
Maybe a part of normal game mode, not dub mode.
No, because I didn't touch this one.
I went to dub or...
I went to the freestyle, actually.
Wait, let me double check.
Yeah, they're right there.
What the heck?
No!
Why did they disappear?
I even checked!
What?
How?
No, I didn't merge any folders, you guys!
Look, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
They're all...
They're missing from the thing, but they're right here.
See?
You can see.
Metal Gear Awesome.
and Mexican riding.
But there's all these folders in between that don't show up.
I only went to freestyle earlier.
I only went to these before.
It's for game show mode?
Oh, I'm a liar then.
I straight up lied, maybe.
Wait, what's the difference?
No, why is it game show only?
Me and I like.
Maybe I didn't realize.
No!
Game show is fun?
Yeah, but I'm by myself.
Hmm.
Let's get through the ones that I have.
If we feel like doing these.
I'll do them.
Game show mode picks some random ones and have you read
them.
Dub mode makes you dub over a long continuous clip.
I don't mind the continuous clip.
It's designed to be done solo.
That's it.
So, I'm guessing if we pick one of these though, we could
just do the game mode.
Here, like, oh, I see, I see, I see.
Well, okay, because it is MGS Master Collection Volume 2
release day, we will do, we'll start with a Metal Gear Solid
4.
cutscenes what if that really really long one is in here now
i don't want you guys to hear me i don't want you guys to
hear me so i probably will be but the way my interface works
is i can't mute my only myself and have you guys not hear
the music or like you guys can still hear the music so i'm
unfortunately just going to have to mute the entire thing um
so you'll just have to not hear any music while i'm dubbing
yeah yeah yeah welcome to the choicer voicer i'm shay i'll
be your host for today's game why is she a slime girl is
vinnie into something that i'm not like aware of oh that's
me hi hi everybody hi hello hello the best voicer in the
land player and in this We have wonderful panel of judges.
I'm excited to see how this pans out.
For any new viewers at home, the goal is for contestants to
expertly match various audio clips using their own voice.
So we'll do the game show version first, and then we'll go
and do the dub style after this.
Oh.
I am lightning.
The rain transformed.
Did I do it?
Good job!
Let's hear that!
I didn't even get a warning.
I'm scared.
They just did it all of a sudden.
Wait, my mic's too low.
I don't know how.
Oh wait.
Actually, you know what?
It's probably taking from the wrong...
I don't know.
It won't let me change my mic.
mic hmm maybe this two times amplify well four times amplify
audio input device above the sliders oh oh wait hold on I
don't think it showed anything but just Just in case.
Input.
Voice.
Yeah.
Okie dokie.
I hope it's not too quiet.
I am lightning.
Lorraine transformed.
I think I did a good job.
I like it, but which of our judges will vote for your
performance?
So edgy.
I want the ones where you're dubbing the clips though.
Lightning.
The rain transformed.
Okay.
Oh, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Try to jerk it around as hard as you can.
Can I redo it?
No!
I gotta turn down.
It's too loud.
Do you like to breathe?
Everybody.
Oh.
Okay.
Try to jerk it around as hard as you can.
No!
Oh, this is the final round.
I'm no hero.
Never was.
Never will be.
Oh.
Let's hear that, how that turned out.
I'm no me.
never was never will be oh everybody will like it close the
match is concluded see what my final score is did I pass
not enough
guys I don't think I'm I don't think I'm suited for this
Well, let's go to the dub mode.
I've got some things here.
We do have more Metal Gears.
Only a little bit.
Oh, I completely forgot to like...
Well, for those, we didn't need to hide it.
I think for the games, we'll be fine.
It's really like Shrek.
Maybe my hero.
Nah, it's probably fun.
What do they know?
In my book, you're pretty good.
I scratched my mic.
Why am I giving a dream's workspace?
No, that was the perfect snake bird!
You're the minnowsest minto.
Oh, am I the mintoest minto?
You can customize the host and player.
Yeah, it didn't give me the option to though, so weird.
Maybe it's under, is it under the...
Customize.
Ah, here we go.
Me, I'm gonna be...
I'll be solid, Snake.
And the studio... No, the judges will be...
I don't know what this means.
The awesome...
What does that mean?
What would happen if you tried to dub yourself?
I don't know.
Credited voice actress Amid to find Tom!
The game scores you on how accurately you match the wave So
don't worry about how good you are you could technically get
a hundred percent score by doing monkey noises loud enough
Wait, okay, we'll do another we'll do another game show
We'll do oh my gosh Do you think the phantom pain would have
such a lust for revenge?
We'll do
We'll do sons of Liberty we'll do sons of Liberty
Five rounds.
Shade.
This is snake.
Oh my god, he talked.
The legendary soldier, solid snake.
I can't.
Okay.
Oh, this one's short.
Look, your favorite.
Explosives.
Who is this?
Who
is this?
Who is this?
Who is this guy?
Mr. Dink?
Who is a Mr. Dink?
Look!
Your favorite explosives!
I was too caught off guard.
Oh my god.
Nobody likes it.
It's so easy to be through praise.
Unlimited horse and law have worked.
Unbelievable.
Ah, so true.
Just give me to the next one, please.
Tough crowd.
It's the enemy.
I need help.
Soldier!
It's so cute!
It's the enemy.
I need help!
Everybody feel pretty good.
Why
does this feel like a fever dream?
I'm pretty good, you guys!
No problem.
Nice, nice.
No problem, baby.
Alright, I'm ready?
Hmm?
Biden?
I'm eating right now.
Get back to me later.
Eww!
What is the gesture?
I was holding a burger.
I was holding a hamburger.
You guys don't hold your burgers like this?
Like that?
You don't hold your hamburgers like this?
Oh no, I couldn't remember it at all.
Riden?
I'm eating right now.
I'll give me one later.
Boys, I was too full of burger.
To remember.
Oh my god.
No, it's so over.
Unbelievable.
Okay, round four.
We did five rounds, right?
Five of them?
No!
That is not Solid Snake!
What is the photo?
I don't think that is actually a solid that's definitely not
solid snake
no that is not solid snake no why did I have like a pseudo
british accent no that's gaseous snake actually you're
pretty good let's go no problem oh my gosh are we gonna make
it okay final round you guys final round let's do this let's
do this what
mo mo Oh When does he say this?
You're pretty good Oh Wait, that's so good The different
pretty goods are so good
Okay I think I've I think I want to Hey,
what?
That's the best you can do, eh?
How could you be big bosses, son?
But I...
Is
it an average?
Meat?
That one was fun.
I actually do want to do the phantom pin.
We'll do four rounds because it's spooky.
These are fine.
okay this is snake this is snake not the sneaking I mean I
can't get over it I can't get it get it out of my face get
it out of my sight I can't I can't look at it all right a
weapon to surpass metal gear
why is he look that's even shiny oh weapon to surpass metal
gear is that a metal gear reference it must be pretty good
pretty good
ridiculous ridiculous revolver schnauz a lot how much can
you smell with that thing he looks like a dog like a he
looks like a doxen but he's supposed to be an a lot okay
that one got that one that one distracted me because of the
picture but I this is serious this is serious round two
major I'm burning okay
let's hear how that when did he say this major I'm burning
I'm skull face more emotion than he gets we can never get
freaking revolver shalashaska Asalad down there at the end
he is a tough cookie to crack that guy over never votes for
me never votes for me never votes for me
no problem wow that was a score though okay round three
cause i'm already a demon oh not this one
guys guys i'm already a demon i don't think i got a good one
on this one though you're pretty good you're pretty good
what Oh my god!
So close!
No problem.
Is that the threshold?
Did we beat the game?
Okay, final round, final round.
Rocket punch!
You're pretty good.
Oh my god!
Oh my- Uh, my final score?
No, keep going?
Okay, good.
Excellent snake.
The age has to slow you down one bit.
On the last one I wanted to do too.
Let's go.
Very good, very good, very good.
Now we're gonna go into the dub mode.
we're gonna do we're gonna do some other things I want to do
like we'll do this one sort clips by character okay okay or
we could do randomize we'll do randomize excellent work
Minto rocket finds only first take mute clip audio is that a
mute it the entire time or i can hear it the first time and
then mute it while i record it's better by character don't
mute clip audio okay i think it's mute the entire time okay
okay by characters better okay i don't really have a
preference so we can start oh my gosh i'm excited here we go
Minto, did you gain a dimension?
Why do you refuse to gain a power?
What?
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, it's Virgil.
Okay, yeah.
Why do you refuse to gain a power?
Okay, I got it.
Okay, good.
The power of our father, Sparta.
Okay.
He's so quiet, right?
I had to turn it up.
I'll turn it up even more.
The power of our father, Sparta.
Okay, okay, nice.
Foolishness.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Might controls...
Wait, I'm sorry, this is clip 4 out of 20!
It's not just 20 for Virgil, right?
No way.
40 out of the...
I mean, 20 out of the entire thing, right?
It'll fly by.
Okay, okay, okay.
What was it?
Might controls...
Okay.
okay nice next and without strength you cannot protect
anything the cutoff oh no okay okay we got this we got this
okay let alone yourself all right
all right yes now the spell will be broken okay okay sorry i
keep having a mute
i think this first bit here i accidentally bumped my mic my
bad
i see a devil inside you has awakened as well
he'll be like whatever i say
Okay, okay.
All right.
Father?
I don't have a father.
Oh, we're on the Dante.
We're on the Dante.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wow.
Arten, Rohani.
Thank
you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Father?
I just don't like you.
That's all.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Nice 50.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, no, I can't spoil how I'm going to sound.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, no.
These are all just like, oof, voices.
I don't think I did that one too much.
Okay.
Next.
It's just breathing.
breathing.
Heavy breathing.
Okay.
The face is killing me.
We're almost there.
Is it more breathing?
I'm gonna lose it.
Stop giving me these prompts.
Stop it.
Oh no, why is it so big?
Why is this part so...
Why is it so loud looking?
Why?
This is just yelling!
Okay.
It's really long too.
I'm excited for you to watch this now.
I think it's fun that we only we do it in clips and then we
watch the full thing at the end.
What was it?
Do you finally have it?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, this I forgot.
I was like, who the heck is Arkham?
I could not remember this guy.
Wait.
We should leave.
That actually looks pretty good, no?
Yeah.
For the moment we have all that we need.
I misremembered the long run.
Oh,
shoot.
This is fine.
Oh, that was the last one.
Okay, okay.
Are you guys ready to see the masterpiece?
I'm nervous.
What do I know?
Oh, oh, let's watch.
Let's watch.
I'll turn it up.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't because I'll be loud, huh?
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
I'm like, I'm scared for my debut!
Why do you refuse to gain power?
The power of our father Sparta.
Why am I so loud?
I don't have a father.
I just don't like you.
That's all.
Oh!
Oh my god, it's so tense.
It's so tense.
Foolishness.
That...
Bite controls everything.
And without strength, you cannot protect anything.
Ugh!
Pull it along yourself.
It's so loud!
The effect Finally have it.
Yes.
Now the spell Sparta casts will be broken.
When's all my breathing coming in?
I see.
The devil inside you has awakened as well.
Really?
We shall leave.
For the moment we are all we need.
We need.
Okay.
I've missed up the line.
Sit the bus.
it was so loud though it was so wait if I save it what
happens could you guys could you guys tell that I was
pinching my nose when I was doing Virgil's parts I knew a
dude that looked like heavy breathing Dante oh no we just
witnessed the birth of a legend how can you doubt yourself
when you make such art oh it'll save it it will
oh okay i saved it i saved it all right we can turn the game
back down that was great that was so Go to cinema, what is,
we were at the cinema already, what are you talking about?
I don't need to go, oh, we could have watched it here!
Do you guys want to watch it again?
No, no, no, no, no, it's okay.
You'll get there someday.
There's another scene I want to do.
Let's do, let's do Mexican riding.
22 clips!
Okay, okay, okay.
We could do Mexican rides.
They got deadly premonition in there?
I don't know!
If so, I didn't see it.
What a performance, Bravo.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
No, no, no autographs.
No autographs.
Let's start.
I'm excited.
So you've got some kind of disguise lined up, right?
Kevin all right here we go
all right nothing nothing too fancy hope so you'd be a
little conspicuous just walking the streets all right is
this one quiet too I don't think so we're
just gonna ignore this one yeah well just get into the sewer
system SAP.
We're just gonna not as quiet.
Okay, okay.
We just ignore that line.
Employee's cat girl.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Next.
Hopefully anyone who notices you will just mind their own
business.
Okay.
You sure you want the K-9 9,000 there along for this one.
Alright, alright.
I'm not doing so hot with this guy, you guys.
I'm not doing such a great job with Kevin.
Yep, all set.
Oh, yes, it's time for riding.
Oh, yes.
Wait, let me hear again.
Yep, all set.
Oh yeah.
If there's too many voice clips in the future, you can tick
off the boxes before starting so you only have to do certain
characters.
Oh, that's so handy.
Thank you, Faisenom.
Relax, Kev.
I'll blend right in.
Oh no.
Okay.
Alright.
I had the good Doctor.
Just once along with the repairs.
I'm scared it's starting to sound a little like Marge
Simpson.
I'm scared.
Okay, what was it?
I had the good doctor make some adjustments along with the
repairs.
What do you mean starting to?
Remote piloting and AI wiping have been disabled.
Uh, okay.
This sounds like March Simpson.
Oh, no.
I say let's throw him a bow.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Let's go.
All right.
Next.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I got y'all.
Yeah.
Word play.
My exoskeleton resembles a canine.
Canines enjoy bones.
Oh my.
Oh my god, K9!
He's so cute!
How do I want to do this?
Hold on, hold on.
Wordplay, my exoskeleton resembles a K9.
K9s enjoy bones.
How did I dub this?
I love Blade Wolf.
So cute.
okay amusing on two levels amusing on two levels wait did
they just plus to him
away everything is a middle
okay what oh who is that guy Spanish wait what
Oh, no.
Okay, that's man A.
Cyborg?
Oh, un cyborg?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I woke
up with my mint plush pointing her butt at me.
What that mean?
Sounds like somebody doesn't have their minto control.
contained.
We're out, we're all.
Okay, hold on.
Let's listen again.
Okay.
Next.
Wait, wait.
He just said K, not the essay sombrero K.
It doesn't even say the whole line that's written here.
I tried.
I tried instead.
Whoa,
that one actually ended up being pretty good, I think.
Oh, what?
I guess it could not have been.
I did my brush.
Okay, this one's easy.
Oh, we finished!
We finished!
Don't quit your day job.
Well, this is my day job!
What am I supposed to do?
All right, we're going to the cinema.
Yeah, it's encouraging me.
So true.
So you got some kind of disguise.
lined up right yep i'll sit i hope so you'd be a little
relax kev i'll blend right in yeah well just get into the
sewer system asap hopefully anyone who notices you will just
mind their own business i wish it kept the background you
sure you went the k9 000 there for the search i had the good
doctor make some adjustments along with the repaired remote
piloting and AI wiping have been disabled so yeah I say
let's throw them a bone woof word play my exoskeleton
resembles a canine canines enjoy boards plus two plus two
plus two plus two plus two let's go guys really I just
marched, Simpson!
No!
Who is that, that way?
A mariachi.
No?
A cyborg?
A sobriero.
Is that sobriero, what?
Adios, Amigos.
Were you staying?
Que raro, eh?
I guess I love Vimot.
Vamonos, yeah?
Totally not spotted at all.
Everybody talk to me at once.
Oh my gosh.
Yay!
Yay.
Oh, I didn't get to save that one.
Oh, no.
Blastroop, blastroop, blastroop, blastroop.
Let's do...
Let's try...
We can do a couple more.
Of course.
I want to do Breaking Bad.
But this one I might have to do the Screen Protector for.
Okay.
You think I need it though for just recording?
Well, probably, right?
Credit where credit was strong, bad, imitating Marge.
You might have been a Mexican princess in your past, past
life.
See?
Latina Marge Simpson is my new comp.
Yo, she's...
Sign me up for the Simpsons dub.
I got you.
Spanish dub.
It's a Spanish speaker, you did muy bien.
I can't un hear the margin though.
Gracias!
Muchas gracias!
Danger should be better, you think so?
I am the danger.
Wait, which is this one?
41 clips.
Okay.
This one's a little shorter.
This one's a little short.
I want to do the...
No!
I want to do this one!
I don't care.
It's fine.
I want to do this one.
Even if it's 41 clips.
Seven minutes!
Okay.
Do a danger?
Really?
Homie, unleash my hair inhibitors.
I just want to say...
Say my name.
Heidermar.
Yeah, God damn bright.
That's exactly how it would sound, though, I think.
Okay, we'll do it.
We'll do I am the danger.
what was I thinking Walt please oh maybe we don't need it
it's just a oh wait you think they're gonna get mad at the
voices hearing them maybe you guys can't hear you can
disable some of the characters there were only two I'm not
gonna disable the second character Felizueves, minto it's
Thursday!
Feliz O'Wears!
For short voice clips, I don't know.
Yeah, it could be okay, right?
Okay, I'm gonna record.
Skylar did nothing wrong, by the way.
Let's both of us stop trying to justify this whole thing and
admit you're in danger.
Fine, welcome back, thank you.
I'm going to get rid of the samples.
I think we're okay.
I messed that one up a little bit.
My bad.
Who are you talking to right now?
Oh, no.
Skylar White.
Yo.
Wife of Walter White.
Uh.
Yo.
I missed this one up.
Oh, no.
it up in a row okay who is it you think you see
do you know how much i make a year i mean even if i told you
you wouldn't believe it oh the first take restart no no it's
okay it's okay does she know she can redo clips uh i
actually i don't know that i can dedue clips but also i set
it so that i it's only on the first take buddy because
Because that's more real.
This is real life.
This is not a game.
This is real.
Yo.
Okay.
Do you know what would happen if I suddenly decided to stop
going into work?
Okay.
Why would I pay taxes?
I'm a criminal.
Yo.
Say my name.
Heisenberg.
Gosh dang, right.
I think the first take, wow, he's out.
So real for that, yo.
A business, big enough that it could be listed on the NASDAQ
goes belly up.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Disappears.
It ceases to exist.
These are harder.
This is harder than the Metal Gears.
Okay.
Without me, no.
You clearly don't know who you're talking to, so let me clue
you in.
Okay, nice, nice.
I am not in danger, Skyler.
I am the danger.
Oh, sorry.
I just realized you couldn't hear that one.
I am not in danger, Skyler.
I am the danger.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
You could hear it.
I'm sorry.
I was muted.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, yeah.
A guy opens his door and gets shot and you think out of me.
No.
I am the one who knocks.
Okay.
Oh, it's time.
It's time.
Oh, it's telling me I did a good job again.
Okay, here we go.
To the cinema!
Jesus, what was I thinking?
Walt, please, let's both of us try to stop, justify this
whole thing and admit you're in danger.
It worked, it worked.
Who do you think you're talking to right now?
Who is it you think you see?
Do you know how much I make a year?
I mean, even if I told you, you wouldn't believe it.
Do you know what would happen if I suddenly decided to stop
going into work?
Business, big, big enough that it could be listed on the
NASDAQ, goes belly in.
It disappears.
It ceases to exist.
Without me.
No, you clearly, you don't know who you're talking to, so
let me clue you in.
I'm not in danger, Skyler.
I am the danger.
A guy opens his door and gets shot, and you think that of
me?
No, I am the one who knocks.
Oh, um...
Why is this play every time?
I thought it was only because it was...
I thought it was only because it was Arrided.
Yay, she said the line!
Yeah!
I want to do the obsession diners thingies let's do this one
let's do this one
minus 10 intimidation to moe to crime boss that's that's
where you're wrong because it'll it's like how do you say
You'll...
Expect the unexpected!
Yeah!
Homie, I'm the one who knocks.
Minto is knocking on my door, guys.
What should I do?
Would you let me in?
Burn down!
Thank you so much for the time you get in!
Thank you!
Let me hear it again.
Bear, I love you so, so, so, so much.
So, so, so, so, so.
so okay five so so so so
okay i don't think i could live without you
i'm dead so you know yeah yes more than anyone
all right yeah
Okay.
Minto did Walt's monologue perfectly.
Brian Cranston, on the other hand, could never sing Snake
here.
You're so right.
Man.
We're just stomping all over these people's careers here.
No.
Oh, here we're still here.
Oops, I was late.
No.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
I think I'm just gonna go through these.
I think I'm gonna zoom through them.
And then I'll unmute once I'm done.
Okay, I'm almost done, I think.
Oh, I'm on 10 out of 20.
Gentle Eye Boo Get Ready.
This is the closest we'll get to.
Minto Yandere ASMR.
Why does it sound like...
My mumbler.
Please enunciate.
Does your dad really have cancer?
Hmm.
Hold on.
What?
Okay.
Oh, it's like overlapping.
Interesting.
I'm wondering how they'll do this.
Okay.
No!
Oh.
Oh, it's gonna be- this is- I wonder how it'll sound.
Okay.
That one I could hear.
The others I couldn't hear.
Yeah, they just overlap the-
We are.
Okay.
It's okay.
We are.
Okay.
We're almost there.
I mean, you're supposed to be doing Bear's lines.
I am!
What do you mean?
What it was?
Oh.
Oh, he keeps saying we are, and it's making me think of one
piece.
We are.
Having a nice day.
is it time
don't quit your day job go to the cinema i boo i love you so
so so so much i don't think i could live without you
You don't want me more than anyone in the world?
Yes, more than anyone.
Minto.
Do you really own an MGS patchy swap?
No.
No, no, no, no.
Nami?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't do
that!
I thought we were having a nice date!
We are.
Why does it matter?
I thought we were having a nice date.
We are.
It's okay.
Wait,
I just realized everybody in the theater is...
This is Rising!
Is that why everybody in the theater is going crazy?
style because they're yay that one was fun that one was fun
to do let's see last one i'll do is decu versus totoroki oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah holy flanders thank you so much
for the tank thank you so much thank you thank you Did you
see that universal?
Japan had one piece Jurassic Park crossover art.
That's so cute!
Oh no!
Vince obsessed with me!
What will I do?
Oh no!
What will you do?
Alright.
Not Deku.
I gotta put- I gotta get my like...
My super anime voice!
My anime Shonen voice that I can use for anime.
Oh,
we're Todoroki first, okay, okay.
Okay, I gotta get my, okay, this is Todoroki, Todoroki Deku,
completely different, okay.
All right, still hate bear, but Jan Minto would have worked
on me.
Don't say that.
I can't believe you made us play bear.
What is it?
I'm playing this so straight, you guys.
I'm playing it so straight.
Pretty sure lightning just struck outside, the thunder shook
the whole room.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Stay safe, Phil.
It's okay to use your power to become who you want to be.
Well, I think that's his mom.
Oh, no, we're doing the breathing.
Okay, okay.
Fraud.
Oh.
You're fraud.
Okay.
Sorry, I keep forgetting to...
Even though you want to win this battle.
Okay.
I did it again, sorry.
I wanted to.
I'll be a hero.
Okay.
With those injuries, in this hopeless situation, don't blame
me for what happens next.
Uh oh.
No!
Guys, my thing just froze.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
It says not responding.
Oh, it crashed.
No.
He froze it, yeah, with his left side or his right side.
Oh, man.
Man, I even had it in the compatibility.
Wait, hold on.
Control-Alt-Delete.
Where is it?
And tag.
Ah.
What we'll do is I will redo it, but I'll do only Deku and
see if maybe we can just do his voice only.
Compatibility.
Yeah.
Gonna do a part two to the stream one of these days.
Yeah?
Dumb mode.
Deku.
And we'll do only Deku.
Oi, I could be all my...
I wanna be all my...
And Todoroki's mom, that's easy.
Okay, that's only nine clips.
We should be able to make this.
Oh!
But I'll start a new one because...
Actually...
can i do it it's yours your quirk not his oh my gosh it's
yours your quirk not his well some of them are gonna be
totoroki i guess
what do you say amazing amazing i'm also amazing every time
amazing out you guys i'm only eating cord yeah amazing i'm
amazing right No, I'm maze maxing.
Optinol 8.
Scream like your charging, my charging up a huge attack.
Wrong your.
It should be.
Y-O-U-Postrophe R-E.
Scream like you are, you're.
Optimal eight.
Okay.
Again?
Optional.
Scream like you're charging up a huge attack.
I wish I could do that one again.
I thought he said, come at me with your wolf.
power all
right I should have oh I should have put on my reverb for
that it's a ghost what one one big long-lasting scream like
it's your final attack that's not at all what that sounded
like
It's okay to use your power.
Okay.
Here we go.
This is the one we heard before.
Why did I say it like that?
Doria, don't tell me you were trying to save young Todoroki
this whole time.
Oh, I'm all might, you guys.
Nice.
All of them could be killed.
Okay.
I think that's it.
Let's watch.
need to go to the cinema for this to use my left side no
it's yours your quirk not his it's okay to use your power to
become who you want to be hey who is that who is that that's
not me medoria don't tell me we're trying to save young
toadroki this whole time
oh they took away my my toadroki voices i wanted to I'll be
a hero.
You will live up to the reason I created you!
Wait, who's that?
Oh, that's Endeavor.
That's right.
This is so emotional.
Amazing!
With those injuries, in this hopeless situation.
Don't blame me for what happens next.
Oh, filter.
It's fine.
Probably.
I wonder what's gonna be killed.
me with your full power, Todoroki!
Wow.
Hey, they didn't use my...
I don't think.
Shonen anime debut in?
I can debut in any shonen anime anytime.
I mean, I could be the protagonist.
Listen to me.
I sound like I have every power inside me I think the more I
continue using like an anime shonen voice the more I start
sounding like super constipated you know Wow that was a time
you guys that was pretty fun that was pretty fun I hope you
enjoyed my fingers what's happening we're okay we're okay
let me out you little eyeball and me out you um this is fun
this is fun i hope you guys had fun too try voicing timmy
turner wait you think i could find one real quick hold on i
want to try voicing timmy turner wait i want to actually
try.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm going to search the website.
Wait, um, dub mode?
I see how it is.
Oh my gosh, they had the mysterious ticking noise from
Potter Puppet Pals.
O's, enjoy my O's.
Wait, hold on.
Can I search?
Can I search on this site?
Hmm.
Dub mode.
Filters maybe?
Contains fairly odd parents.
Apply?
I don't think so.
Maybe not.
No!
Wait!
We'll finish on one last one then.
This one actually said that it was not safe for work.
When are we getting a Vegeta Minto?
It's kind of hard to search on the side.
I'm not gonna lie.
All right, I'm just gonna mute and we'll do it all in one
take.
Oh, I can get rid of the filter.
Why you guys need the ears?
First time.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to do this.
Okay, sorry for all that.
Wow, 56.
That might be my best score today.
Okay, let's watch.
First time that I trusted with great force.
Every angle it penetrates until...
With great strength
In the end We are all satisfied And you are set free
Beautiful
Beautiful What's meet everybody?
Thank you so much It's a nice show Bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye Bye bye bye bye bye bye Bye bye
bye You are set Free
Thank you, bye bye bye Bye bye bye You are the one who talks
Thank you so much, bye bye